[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en donde
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 soi santiago lópez gonzález a
continuación algunos de los temas que
vamos a tratarlos
eeuu colombia y ecuador comenzarán a
aplicar una tercera dosis de la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 a pesar del pedido de
la o ms de no dar inicio a esa fase de
vacunación hasta tanto otros países que
están rezagados en la inmunización
puedan ponerse al día estos tres países
siguen también los pasos de república
dominicana uruguay y chile que ya han
inoculado a una con una tercera dosis a
un sector específico de su población la
tercera ola de contagio hacia estragos
en méxico hace estragos en ese país esta
semana el país superó ya los 250.000
muertos por kobe 19 en esa misma semana
superaron los contagios diarios al
registrar más de 28 mil casos
confirmados mientras que la cifra de
muertos diarios también batió récord 940
personas tenemos un reporte desde ciudad
de méxico para conocer detalles de la
situación y también la respuesta de las
autoridades y de la población ante estas
cifras y también la oms se alertó sobre
la difícil situación en la que está
haití un país que fue sacudido por un
sismo de 7.2
buena parte de su infraestructura
hospitalaria y está en plena pandemia de
kobe 19 por supuesto ahora la prioridad
no es la vacunación no es la mascarilla
no es el distanciamiento es rescatar y
dar apoyo a los sobrevivientes pero la
pandemia de kobe 19 continúa entonces
tendremos un reporte desde puerto
principio para conocer la situación que
se está viviendo allí para comenzar el
programa demos un vistazo primero a las
cifras el avance de la pandemia de kobe
19 esta semana en algunos países vamos a
hablar de casos fallecidos de países
como por ejemplo brasil que llega ya a
los 20 puntos 4 millones de casos
confirmados es el que más casos tiene en
la región más de 500.000 personas han
fallecido también allí en brasil por el
coronavirus le sigue en la lista
argentina que tiene 5.1 casos
confirmados 5.1 millones de casos
confirmados y más de 100 mil personas
han perdido la vida colombia tiene 4.8
millones de casos un poco menos que
argentina pero contabilizan más
fallecidos colombia tiene 123 mil
personas que ya han fallecido que han
sido contabilizadas
las autoridades locales contabilizan 1.4
millones de casos más de 26.000 personas
han fallecido en canadá finalizamos este
recorrido en guatemala que tiene más de
420 mil casos y unos 11.300
fallecidos
y se conecta hasta ahora la doctora rosa
maría guangzhou ella es infectóloga
doctora en ciencias médicas y la jefa de
la división de investigación de clínica
de la facultad de medicina de la unam
ella nos atiende desde la capital
mexicana o la doctora aguán gracias por
estar con nosotros y ya lo decíamos
vemos que la variante delta rápidamente
está extendiéndose por diferentes países
en la región y el mundo pero que hay de
las otras variantes que estábamos
registrando a lo largo de estos meses
está ya el comportamiento de delta
haciendo que se vuelva la variante
predominante en el mundo entero
así buenas noches a todos muchas gracias
por la oportunidad de platicar con
ustedes
así es la variante delta está haciendo
prevalente ya también en el mundo y
también en nuestro país originalmente
empezamos a ver la variante gamma
primero en la parte sureste electro por
cancún por lo que es yucatán y quintana
roo ahí teníamos un incremento de la
variante gamma pero más o menos por mayo
1 empezamos a detectar los primeros
casos de delta en nuestro país y
actualmente esta es la variante
predominante al igual que en el resto
del mundo nos en méxico existe ya una
tercera ola esta tercera ola está la
gran mayoría de los casos son por la
variante delta y pues como bien lo
mencionado previamente tenemos el hemos
llegado al pico máximo de toda la
pandemia en el número de casos hemos
roto récord en el número de casos en un
solo día
doctora wong sabiendo y conociendo las
condiciones de américa latina en donde
hay pobreza hay poca infraestructura
hospitalaria donde la gente no se cuida
del todo como corresponde no usan la
mascarilla como debe ser porque la
variante delta todavía no está digamos
en explosión digámoslo así como ha
estado en europa o como lo estuvo en
india porque no hay más casos porque no
estamos ante una ola generalizada en
nuestra región con la variante delta
dadas las condiciones que tenemos
bueno puede ser cuestión de tiempo no
hay que recordar que el coronavirus se
transmite precisamente de persona a
persona y esto es una cuestión de
movilidad
entonces la variante que este
predominando pues va a depender de la
movilidad que hay de un lugar hacia otro
entonces esta variante delta inició
primero en la india como todos bien
saben en abril hubo muchísimos casos en
india de tanto casas como fallecimientos
en un solo día llegaron a atender hasta
400 mil casos y después el siguiente
país que reportó una gran cantidad de
casos fue inglaterra y de ahí se fue
eeuu y bueno específicamente en la parte
norte si tenemos una
predominancia de delta lo que se sabe de
la variante delta es que si tiene una
mayor
tasa de transmisión
algunos han calculado un ere 0 de 6 y
otros de 9 incluso osea que esto quiere
decir que una persona puede contagiar a
seis personas más a diferencia del virus
original que era una persona contagiaba
dos o tres personas más entonces si
tiene este potencial de transmisión muy
muy alto y bueno pues puede ser cuestión
de tiempo lo que empiece a ver mayor
movilidad de las áreas donde hay una
gran cantidad de casos de delta y que se
puedan ir hacia la región de sudamérica
pues en este momento en sudamérica es la
labarthe gamma la que está predominando
pero pues empiezan a ver también casos
de venta
doctora wong le transmito una de las
preguntas que nos hacen algunos de
nuestros televidentes a través de las
redes sociales y es una pregunta
obligada también que tanto nos están
protegiendo las vacunas actuales contra
esta variante en específica que es la
que está tomando y la que está ganando
más terreno está tomando predominación
sí claro esa es una pregunta muy muy
interesante muy importante lo que haré
escrito pues los ingleses y
pues israel
ellos tienen una gran cantidad de la
población sobre todo mayores de 60 años
que ya están vacunados con dos dosis de
vacuna de rn a mensajero que es la
vacuna de facer
para casos graves y hospitalización
tanto la vacuna de astrazéneca como la
vacuna de facer tienen una protección
bastante adecuada tiene una eficacia
vacunal para evitar en
hospitalizaciones en 92 y 96 %
respectivamente y en el caso de pues
enfermedad grave pues también nos
importantemente lo que sí es que por
ejemplo las la vacuna de facer que
mostró en una fase 3 una eficacia
vacunal del 95 por ciento desde que baja
a 86 por ciento con la variante delta y
en el caso de astrazéneca baja a 60 con
la variante delta algo que también es
importante es esto está esta eficacia
vacuna que se obtiene con dos dosis con
una sola dosis no es suficiente la que
acá se vacuna les de 30 por ciento y
entonces estamos viendo muchos casos de
personas que tienen una sola dosis o que
no están vacunados que son los que están
llegando a los hospitales graves y que
han fallecido no básicamente y ya se
está hablando de una tercera dosis ya le
voy a preguntar por ese tema doctora
gwenn pero antes de dar paso a esa
pregunta quiero que veamos algunas de
las cifras sobre el avance que ha tenido
la variante del está en nuestro
continente vayamos a algunos de los
países en donde ya la variante es
prácticamente la que más se impone allí
por ejemplo
en eeuu de los casos testeados en las
últimas dos semanas el 98 punto 23 por
ciento de ellos corresponden a la
variante delta en brasil el 72 punto 21
por ciento en costa rica el 51 punto 61
por ciento mientras que en chile llega
ya al 10 punto 47 por ciento del total
de los casos como les digo que han sido
testeados en las últimas dos semanas
terminó esto con colombia en donde ya
representa el 2.13 por ciento de los
casos pasó ahora preguntarle doctora
wong por la tercera dosis lado ms había
hecho la advertencia que por favor no
empezaran los países a vacunar con esta
tercera dosis hasta tanto algunos
territorios que estaban rezagados
avanzarán un poco en la en la vacunación
pero los gobiernos han tomado las
decisiones por su cuenta esto entonces
no se genera un desequilibrio a la hora
de lograr la inmunización a nivel global
sí bueno esta es una pregunta muy
interesante y muy importante
para poder combatir el virus debe de
haber una un esfuerzo a nivel global que
fue lo que hicimos para poder eliminar
la viruela por ejemplo mucha gente se
infectó mucha gente tenía inmunidad pero
también se aplicaban muchas vacunas
alrededor del mundo con esto logramos
que todos tuvieran inmunidad contra el
virus y por lo tanto el virus
desapareció de la faz de la tierra
mientras que haya algún lugar en el
mundo en donde haya casos y estas
personas se muevan de un país a otro
pues hay la posibilidad de que el virus
está entrando a nuestros países y que
ataque a nuestras poblaciones y entre
más se replique el virus mayor
posibilidad hay de que haya nuevas
variantes que puedan pues escapar a los
anticuerpos generados por la vacuna o
generados por enfermedad previa entonces
esto tiene que ser un esfuerzo conjunto
de toda la humanidad para poder
convertir el virus lo que tenemos que
hacer es vacunar a la mayor cantidad de
gente posible en el menor tiempo posible
para poder evitar que la gente se está
infectando que se replique él mismo y
que se desarrollen estas variantes que
las pueden aceptar después doctora wong
rápidamente ya para para terminar esta
entrevista hay mucha presión sobre las
compañías farmacéuticas para que
desarrollen otra vacuna que tenga una
efectividad mucho más prolongada ya
usted mencionaba que algunas pues
empiezan a perder su efecto en el
organismo pasados unos meses después de
la segunda dosis cuando ya se tiene el
esquema completo hay mucha presión en la
industria hay mucha presión entre la
comunidad científica para que
desarrollen una vacuna mucho más
efectiva
bueno más que presión en la industria es
esta presión que tenemos en la humanidad
y los científicos de desarrollar una
vacuna que sea eficaz contra las
ternadas variantes lo que hemos visto es
que la eficacia vacunal baja con ciertas
variantes y todavía no sabemos si
precisamente por esta replicación tan
importante del virus porque cada vez hay
más personas que están infectadas este
virus siga teniendo esta posibilidad de
este poder cambiando de mutar y de
generar nuevas variantes que puedan ser
mucho más agresivas o que vuelvan a dar
la enfermedad en forma mucho más grave
entonces sí muchas compañías
farmacéuticas muchos centros de
investigación alrededor del mundo
universidades están desarrollando
vacunas con diferentes estrategias para
tratar de hacer esto precisamente si es
un punto muy importante doctorada mar y
agua aunque en ciudad de méxico muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa y
explicado todos estos temas para la
audiencia muchas gracias
y ya son varios los países que han
optado por la aplicación de la tercera
dosis en la repubblica o en la región
república dominicana chile y uruguay ya
están inoculando esta tercera dosis
mientras que los gobiernos de colombia
eeuu y ecuador anunciaron recientemente
que van a comenzar a inocular la muy
pronto para un sector determinado de la
población
bueno y contrario al pedido de la o ms
que buscaba permitir a los países
rezagados en la vacunación para que
podrán acceder a ellas y pudieran tomar
un poco de ventaja a eeuu decidió
iniciar la inoculación de la tercera
dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19 a
partir del 20 de septiembre otros países
como ya lo decíamos ecuador y colombia
después de estudiar la situación optaron
también por esta misma medida
una nueva fase en el plan de vacunación
de eeuu autoridades de salud anunciaron
que el 20 de septiembre comenzará la
aplicación de la tercera dosis el motivo
la pérdida de efectividad de la vacuna
con el tiempo y los temores que desata
la variante del está ampliamente
presente en el país serían priorizados
los trabajadores de la salud de hogares
de ancianos y personas de la tercera
edad
no quieres estar detrás del virus es
mejor prevenir que perseguir este hierve
en 'chasing after una decisión que no ha
gustado en la organización mundial de la
salud
claramente los datos actuales no indican
que se necesiten refuerzos desde la oms
se dijeron este miércoles que sólo 10
países han administrado el 75 por ciento
de vacunas en el mundo mientras los
países de bajos ingresos sólo han
inoculado un 2%
peticiones a las que respondió el
presidente joe biden en una rueda de
prensa ahora que algunos líderes están
diciendo que los estadounidenses no han
de tener su tercera dosis antes que el
resto tenga la primera no estoy de
acuerdo
debemos cuidar a los estadounidenses y
ayudar a el mundo al mismo tiempo
byd en hacer referencia a las
declaraciones a principios de agosto del
director ejecutivo pedrosa da nombre
jesus quien había pedido una moratoria
hasta septiembre en la aplicación de
terceras dosis para que el 10% de la
humanidad fuese vacunado de forma
similar también habló el martes el
presidente de malawi lazarus se acuerda
ha llegado el momento de insistir en que
una vacuna que preserva y apoye el
derecho humano a la vida de una persona
pertenece a todas las naciones
independientemente de quien la descubrió
discusiones que se dan cuando un estudio
de atención médica israelí reveló que
una tercera dosis de facer es un 86%
efectiva en mayores de 60 años
y vamos a ver otros temas destacados de
la semana en eeuu con manzana nuestra
corresponsal en la ciudad de nueva york
para conocer más detalles de la
situación allí hola mamen y novedades en
torno a un pasaporte sanitario allí en
la ciudad de nueva york
si a partir de esta semana a santiago
todos los que quieran entrar a un
negocio una discoteca un bar una
cafetería un gimnasio una peluquería
tendrán que enseñar una tarjeta como
ésta de vacunación mostrar que por lo
menos tienen una dosis administrada o
ese pasaporte digital que acredita que
han recibido esta vacuna es una
iniciativa del ayuntamiento de nueva
york para impulsar la vacunación y que
no se quede estancada como ha ocurrido
en otras zonas del país eso que aquí
nueva york no estamos tan mal con casi
un 60% de la población con esas dos
dosis ya puestas las primeras cuatro
semanas va a ser un periodo de prueba
para que los negocios se vayan
acostumbrando pero a partir del 13 de
septiembre 600 funcionarios saldrán a
las calles de nueva york a garantizar
que esta ley se cumple si no es así las
multas a las que se enfrentan los
negocios son entre mil y cinco mil
dólares como ha hecho el alcalde bill de
blasio si usted quiere disfrutar de la
ciudad de nueva york en todo su
esplendor ya sabe lo que tiene que hacer
vacunarse
estábamos algunas cifras de eeuu son
muchos son casos de la variante delta
registrada allí cuáles son las
impresiones sobre el desarrollo de esta
variante y cómo se ha expandido en eeuu
si según los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades las
hospitalizaciones y las muertes por comí
19 en este país se han vuelto a disparar
además están aumentando también los
contagios y se están alcanzando cifras
nunca vistas antes entre los niños y la
población menor de 50 años en medio de
esta situación la administración de
bailén decide recomendar la
administración de una tercera dosis de
las vacunas de modernas y de facer ojo
que todavía no habla de la ley johnson
and johnson se recomienda esta dosis de
refuerzo cuando hayan pasado ocho meses
después de haber recibido la segunda y
por supuesto siempre que la prueben las
agencias federales sanitarias del país
esta tercera vacuna se va a empezar a
administrar en principio a partir del 20
de septiembre primero se va a empezar
con la población más vulnerable es decir
los ancianos y lo y el personal
sanitario y el propio bailén ha dicho
que él y su mujer recibirán esa tercera
dosis en las próximas semanas amén hay
otros temas destacados alabama se quedó
sin camas para atender pacientes florida
tiene muchísimos casos el gobernador de
texas greg abbott fue diagnosticado con
kobe 19 que dicen al respecto
si en esta nueva ola de la pandemia la
peor parte se la están llevando los
estados del sur del país que como sabéis
han sido los más reacios a utilizar
mascarilla y los que más en contra de la
vacunación han ido porque aquí como
sabéis estos dos asuntos se han
convertido en algo muy político entonces
son los que se están llevando la peor
parte entre ellos alabama donde para que
os hagáis una idea el índice de
vacunación es sólo de un 35 por ciento
comparado con casi un 60 por ciento que
tenemos aquí en nueva york' allí los
sanitarios ya han dado la voz de alarma
porque se han quedado sin camas en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos ante la
avalancha de nuevos casos de kobe 19 que
están recibiendo la situación también es
crítica en texas donde su gobernador uno
de los mayores detractores del uso de la
mascarilla acaba de anunciar que se ha
contagiado del cob y 19 ha dado positivo
se encuentra haciendo una cuarentena en
su casa y constantemente está realizando
le test de kobe 19 porque a pesar de que
estaba vacunado había recibido las dos
dosis sea contra
vale muchas gracias por este reporte
desde nueva york que vamos ahora hasta
venezuela este país está viviendo la
misma problemática que argentina y
bolivia que experimentaron escasez de la
segunda dosis de la vacuna sporting p
carmen cara de 77 años no ha podido
completar su inmunización contra kobe 19
por la escasez de la segunda dosis de la
rusa después ni venezuela le
correspondía la segunda inyección en
junio fuego
nos dijeron que el siguiente día mi hija
por el siguiente día
le dijeron que
no estaban poniendo la vacuna
carmen que sufre de diabetes y es
hipertensa evita salir de casa no puedo
salir tengo mi casa en el pueblo y no
puedo ir no he podido ir tengo un año
convocarme muchos otros que fueron
vacunados con la primera dosis de la
sputnik hoy no tienen la certeza de
cuándo podrán finalizar su inmunización
dado los retrasos en la entrega
afuera de un centro de vacunación
repleto de personas esta anillo alianza
de 76 años informaron que no había
porque una ruta sino la china
el nombre del día para poner a la
segunda
quienes fueron inoculados con la primera
dosis de la russa visitan constantemente
su centro de vacunación en busca de
información casi siempre en vano la
mayoría de estos la única vacuna
disponible la china sino farm sin que
hasta ahora se haya recomendado su
combinación
manuel enrique figuera presidente de la
sociedad venezolana de infectología
define el plan de vacunación del
gobierno de venezuela como político y no
técnico están vacunando sin ningún tipo
de estructura sin ningún tipo
organización sin planificación con
desorden grandes colas grandes
información las personas ni siquiera
saben que van a recibir donde lo van a
recibir el gobierno a nicolás madura de
acuerdo con rusia la entrega de 10
millones de unidades pero sólo se conoce
que llegaron al país
1.430.000 y a medida que la escasez de
vacunas se hace más evidente en los
centros de vacunación es mucho más
difícil poder ingresar a ellos
custodiados por militares y policías
nicole kolster france24 caracas
y la tercera ola de contagio en méxico
está causando estragos el país rompió
todos sus récords en solo una semana con
más de 28 mil contagios diarios así
están las cosas en ese país los casos ya
superan los 3.1 millones mientras que
los fallecidos ya superan los 252 mil
víctimas el porcentaje de personas
vacunadas con el esquema completo
alcanza en ese país el 23 punto 44 por
ciento de la población
vamos a conocer más detalles con mario'
carbonell en ciudad de mexico hola mario
gracias por acompañarnos hoy y qué dicen
las autoridades de estas cifras
alarmantes que dicen también los
mexicanos
así es ha sido una semana con datos de
alarma y todavía el martes el
subsecretario de salud hugo lópez gatell
hablaba de que hacia finales de mes
podríamos ver el declive de esta tercera
ola camino ya a una estabilización sin
embargo pues al día siguiente el
miércoles fue cuando se presentaron esta
cifra récord se superó la barrera de los
250 mil muertos por sharp con dos en un
lapso de 24 horas se reportaron más de
28.000 contagios y 940 fallecimientos lo
que también son marcas históricas
y a pesar de ello al día siguiente el
jueves el propio lópez gatell en una
reunión con gobernadores del país
sostuvo que pues ya la curva a pesar del
alza de los contagios la curva comienza
a aplanarse y que empieza a ver signos
tempranos de desaceleración
lo cierto es que hay pues inquietud
entre la población algunas encuestas
como por ejemplo la más reciente del
periódico y financiero
reporta que 59% de los consultados
considera que está muy poco por la
situación el presidente de lópez obrador
hay que decirlo no ha tocado el tema del
alza de contagios recientemente en sus
conferencias mañaneras lo que concentra
su atención por ahora pues es temas como
la revocación de mandato y la reforma
electoral mario está saturada la red
hospitalaria o el sistema todavía puedo
aguantar un poco más
según los datos oficiales la ocupación
de camas de hospitalización general en
el país está entre el 54 o 55 por ciento
y en camas con ventilador se ubica en
48% esto refiere que no estaríamos en
una situación crítica de atención a la
población que padece con 1.019 sin
embargo también de acuerdo con los
propios datos de la red de información
hospitalaria hay actualmente más de 260
hospitales que reportan un cupo superior
al 70% en camas de hospitalización
general y más de 100 unidades médicas
con cupos superior al 70% en camas de
ventilador es también común ver algunos
hospitales como el instituto nacional de
enfermedades respiratorias que
frecuentemente pues hay un aviso de cupo
casi lleno
-mario contrario a algunos países de
suramérica donde las cifras han
comenzado a bajar méxico parece que es
todo lo contrario qué es lo que está
sucediendo allí para que esta tercera
ola se esté prolongando tanto
asegura el vocero de la pandemia de
lópez gatell de nueva cuenta que méxico
ya aplica más vacunas diarias que eeuu
sin embargo pues si esto parece no estar
frenando está tercera ola se han
aplicado 79 millones de dosis de vacuna
anti cobit de un total de 94 millones
que han llegado es decir sigue habiendo
una diferencia de 15 millones de dosis
entre las que han llegado al país y las
que se han aplicado y esto pues sigue
generando también algunas dudas algunas
sospechas hay que decir también que
93% de las personas que han sido
hospitalizadas en lo que va del año son
personas que no tenían la vacuna sólo 30
millones de mexicanos tienen actualmente
su esquema completo de vacunación y de
acuerdo con las autoridades pues el
avance en la inmunización ha permitido
que al menos nueve entidades de la
república tengan ya datos a la baja en
cuanto a contagios y fallecimientos
-mario muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de mexico les cuento
brevemente otras noticias destacadas a
lo largo de la semana un lote de 12 mil
510 dosis de vacunas contra el cob y 19
llegó a el salvador se suma a las 10.43
de vacunas que ya han arribado a ese
país centroamericano no muy lejos de
allí en costa rica allí están
experimentando una nueva ola de
contagios debido al rápido avance de la
variante delta esta semana el país
registró 2 mil 311 casos nuevos en
solamente 24 horas está en la cifra más
alta que costa rica ha registrado a lo
largo de la pandemia y en ecuador en
contraste registraron una reducción de
muertes inéditas desde el inicio de la
pandemia con 1.500 fallecidos a lo largo
de esta semana la cifra es alta pero
comparada con las otras es mucho más
bajas es mucho más baja si se compara
con la mortalidad que hubo en este país
al inicio de la pandemia sobre todo en
las provincias de guayas y santa elena
y veamos ahora cómo avanza la vacunación
en el continente americano para el
cierre de esta semana las cifras
corresponden al porcentaje de población
que tiene ya el esquema completo de
vacunación comenzamos con canadá
allí el 65.1 0 1% de la población ya
tiene el esquema completo nos vamos
hasta centroamérica el salvador 33
puntos 69 por ciento de la población
tiene ya el esquema completo en perú ya
alcanza en el 21 puntos 73 por ciento la
vecina bolivia alcanza el 18 puntos 78
por ciento mientras que paraguay ya
alcanza el 14 punto 42 por ciento de la
población con el esquema completo
haití pasa por una situación muy difícil
la oms ya advirtió sobre la necesidad de
garantizar ayuda de la comunidad
internacional a este país que tiene
muchas dificultades para hacer frente a
la pandemia pero el terremoto de 7.2
dejó más de 2.000 personas muertas y
también afectó seriamente la
infraestructura hospitalaria gotson
pierre está allí en puerto príncipe y
nos va a dar más detalles de la
situación que se está viviendo allí
gotzon como están haciendo las
autoridades para poder sortear estas
diferentes crisis que se están
presentando hoy en haití
digamos que cogí 19 es una de las
preocupaciones ahora del gobierno porque
tiene al menos que registrar y coordinar
estas estructuras sanitarias que
intervienen en las zonas afectadas por
el terremoto hay una campaña de
sensibilización contra cubil 19 que
sigue sobre todo por los medios de
comunicación y también por las redes
sociales pero hay menos atención por
parte del público para esto por ejemplo
si bien en las zonas afectadas gente sin
cubrebocas y tampoco no se respeta la
distancia física entre personas
hay que precisar también que haití tiene
una relación un poco particular con kobe
19 hasta ahora
en comparación con otros países de la
región fue menos afectado hasta ahora
desde marzo de 2000
2050 más o menos 20.000 casos
confirmados de kobe 19 y 500 muertos los
haitianos toman mucha medicina
tradicional
gotzon y que tan afectada está la
infraestructura hospitalaria allí el
gobierno está en capacidad de dar
respuesta a estas múltiples crisis que
se le están presentando
y
25 estructuras de salud entre hospitales
centros de salud
dispensarios que fueron
afectadas en las zonas golpeadas por el
terremoto
por ahora hay muchos que hacer para
restablecer todo esto el gobierno
anunció que
estableció una lista de necesidades
primordiales
pero hace falta un plan y el gobierno
tarda mucho a anunciar un comité
nacional de gestión de esta crisis
humanitaria entonces seguro que allí por
ahora no tiene capacidad para enfrentar
esta crisis es cierto lo que funciona es
la solidaridad interna si contraen la
situación es muy complicada y en haití
finalmente quiero preguntarle por la
vacunación está avanzando no está
avanzando está paralizado el proceso
como van
500 mil dosis de vacuna están
disponibles ahora en haití
a vacunación empezó hace un mes y hasta
ahora
23.000 personas fueron vacunadas
el gobierno saca día a día balance de
personas vacunadas el último fue el 18
de agosto y
1300 personas
fueron vacunadas en un día
gracias watson gotson pierre e
informándonos desde puerto principe
ahora demos un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con el hobby 19 destacadas
también en las redes sociales comenzamos
con esta publicación de nuestros colegas
de swissinfo lado ms llama a científicos
a que investiguen orígenes de patógenos
pandémicos la organización quiere
conformar un nuevo grupo científico para
que investigue el origen de patógenos
nuevos que puedan emerger o que puedan
causar epidemias o pandemias como la que
estamos viviendo actualmente el tiempo
en colombia' pública también colombia
aplicará tercera dosis para personas
inmunodeprimidas el anuncio lo hizo el
viceministro de salud luis alexánder
moscoso quien indicó que quienes
presentan déficit de defensas recibirán
un refuerzo de la vacuna contra el cob y
19 la medida fue adoptada como
recomendación del consejo asesor de
vacunas hay en ese país suramericano y
finalizamos con este titular soberana 2
más soberana plus ya son vacunas la
combinación de ambos inmunógenos
inmunógenos del instituto finlay de
vacunas demostró que tiene una eficacia
del 90 y 1.2 por ciento en la prevención
del cob y 19 por lo que ya fue aprobado
para su uso de emergencia en cuba
soberana 2 y soberana plus y también
abdalá son las primeras vacunas
desarrolladas en américa latina' todas
ellas desarrolladas en la isla de cuba
hasta aquí este resumen de kobe 19 la
semana en américa nos volvemos a
encontrar la próxima semana mientras
tanto sigan cuidando el hobby 19 y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]